[Music]
look
all right i got something else for you
matter of fact look
look i seen [ __ ] in my life you [ __ ]
drink now i live a dream
the g wagon this money green on the
bigger things i'm taking one for the
team got a beat sing
[ __ ] ain't always what it's in can't
stop now wesson khan had it locked down
butch came through now i'm bout to lock
a spot down i feel like kobe in his
rookie
yes i'm drawing without the ring young
ginobili with the curly hair
i am mike on the first round like i
leave on the ropes and miss smith for
the first down
remember when i get my first pound
hanging out the whip black 38 and blew
my first rounds
at 16 i was a street [ __ ] i used to
package nickel bags then go and post in
the street with them
these [ __ ] running in the streets with
us ain't never eat with a sea that we
yawn they try and beef with us
face the facts what kind haters that
just know you sent them little shots my
way we come and spread
back then slug probably break his back
let's take it back tie your [ __ ] [ __ ]
up
and hit him with that axe couldn't hold
me like the old shack
punk crack blowing 32 shots up in the
old mac
not against it here old heard [ __ ]
speaking up on the body and when it told
that
all the snitching got the game twisted
and they letting [ __ ] live
down play right the game different
everybody wanna be the man
i seen an og make it to a thousand from
a half gram started stacking now we
bought status
do it right make a couple hundred grand
off a small package
living lavish while we started average
amg head wrestling and v
riding the s classes press paid cartier
glasses
little tragic missing my mans talking to
his ashes
he been gone for some years now told him
we here now
he willing blunts to slow the tears down
still wishing i could see his face
he in a better place gotta retaliate
just play it safe
got a mass with a joker face i know a
[ __ ] caught two three bodies with a
broken a
more wiz i was raised in it i was cool
with all the robbers and thieves know
all the grave diggers
where i'm from it's how they made [ __ ]
and you had to be a killer cop or you a
paid [ __ ]
pick a route and try to make it out cuz
them [ __ ] ain't your friends for a
price they'd take you out
they know
[Music]
yo rest in peace dj shay
rest in peace machine gun black burton
the proof
out right now you know i mean big big
bsf
big result in this [ __ ] and i
feel good
[Music]
y'all [ __ ] should be happy for me why
you're looking like that
yo conversations alone in the mirror i
told myself before the europe
i'd be a homeowner and another
millionaire up my life crazy
but i'm way too busy to tear up so
please keep them broke vibes from
nearest i'm different i'm not the one to
converse by time you mumble your verse i
be in top five company comfortably
gunning for first
rap or either trap one gonna come with
some perks the other coming with a six
foot hole dug in the earth i don't have
numbers looking
i don't got a check stats the [ __ ] good
but i still never text back
i told the plug i need the best batch
just facts i get your queen knocked off
like a chess
match i told my [ __ ] no first class
flights got a lazy
i pulled her on a strip a week after she
dropped the baby she said i'm too
obsessed with money and it drive her
crazy
cause even if the [ __ ] ain't selling
she gotta pay me
[Music]
soprano [ __ ] this [ __ ] this this this
thing this that's griselda [ __ ]
this the [ __ ] they [ __ ] with huh